so welcome um we all good to go so we're
on live streaming we're good to go so
welcome to the financing projects
committee last meeting for
um 2023 I'd firstly like to apologize
for Michael's out foot
um very good very
cheerful um I have no doubt some
complaints on the bluff community board
because he didn't turn up last night at
the meeting like that so anyway um
welcome to members that are watching uh
sorry public that are watching online um
we are going to make a slight change to
the agenda um and we're lucky to have
shami with us from Great South so we
actually go to agenda item five
um and we'll bring be the Callie report
in first so we'll just make that change
and then we'll skip back to the minutes
just so Shamy can come in and talk
through um the pieces related to the
performance um of quarter one so yeah if
you want to come out chy so yes I'll
take apologies first so I think we've
got apologies from M Clark
and Trish Trish although she's not a
member of the committee so can I someone
move and second thanks Leslie thanks R
um all those in favor I I okay uh is
there any Declaration of
interest to related to this meeting no
that's noted um there's no public forum
so we'll get on to item five and uh be
the c quar one performance so Ron's
going to take us through that and then
sh we talk or is available to talk
through anything related to great
ah so it's Tab S on
your on your page 24 on Bard
books thank you check K counselors so um
this is the quarter one performance
report just due to the timing of this
finance and projects committee meeting
it is now about two months actually
since the end of quarter 1 um but um
this report deals specifically with July
August and September um so firstly the
non financial performance um we are
tracking well against comparably where
we were at um last Financial year
there's some good service level
performance across um some of the key
areas of council and the core Services
continue to be delivered well and we're
continuing to see that visitor number
rebound that we were seeing in the last
quarter of the last Financial year post
the covid um updates
um the areas where we are indicating
we're unlikely to achieve performance
are primarily in the satisfaction areas
where the resident survey is showing
that um while it's still possible we may
radically turn around in the next three
quarters it's unlikely um and so um I
will just pass to Patricia if there is
anything she specifically wants to draw
attention to in the area of financial
performance before handing Charmy thank
you speak on great behalf of Great South
um sorry before I hand to you Patricia
I'll just Note One error in the actual
performance report itself in the section
of Great South where it's reporting
against that last indicator um that is
incorrectly not noted as not achieved
for last year that is a typo it should
say
achieved what paid you on the I'll just
find that page for you chair while
Patricia is speaking to the financial
performance performance so um as you all
know the first quarter is always the
hardest quarter um to get whether it's a
fa for the full year so at at the end of
September the um excluding depreciation
we had a surplus of 4 million so that
was 2.6 million better than
forecast but um as we start going
through the year we're expecting that to
um drop as we have um expenditure will
increase this is principally because the
expenditure really hasn't wrapped up
that first quarter and we're expecting
that in the last three quarters that
will catch that up
um and that's perhaps all I was going to
draw attention
to within
that because we've got a slightly
updated version coming through on the
next
paper thank you and then 87 I think is
the board Books page 89 of board books
is where the area is right yep 89
okay shy do you want
k um thank you for having me and through
you chair appreciate the opportunity to
speak uh on behalf of great souths
performance um I um am happy to take any
questions uh I've uh but just as a
general overview quarter 1 has been a
pretty uh standard business as usual
most of our um targets uh seem to be uh
we will'll be on target to achieve those
uh kpis um I would only suppose draw
your attention to the regional Business
Development uh growth
initiatives um and that um is just to
advise the committee about changes to uh
Great South Staffing um in that area so
we had Ben Lewis who was the general
manager of business uh support uh uh he
left us in October this year and we
haven't replaced that position um we've
also had another growth advisor that was
um supporting the Regional business uh
partnership program and the Callahan
Innovation programs uh she also left
earlier however we read advertised uh
just for an executive within that
position and the person who left Sarah
mcferson is now going to join us back on
the 22nd of Jan um so we are very
conscious of cost obviously and trying
to manage uh what we can with uh to the
best of our ability so instead of
replacing a GM for the sake of replacing
a GM we're relooking at restructuring
our
um services to incorporate that within
an existing GM uh
portfolio um and um in the new year when
the new person comes when Sarah comes
back uh we will restructure that to
ensure that we meet the contractual
obligations to MB for RBP program and
Kahan Innovations but also um spearhead
a little bit uh a lot more to catch up
on some of the business engagements we
have lost over this last quarter too so
uh we're confident that we will still
hit those targets uh you I'd like also
like to draw your attention to the fact
that great South no longer manages the
business mentors New Zealand program but
given that this is in the ltp we can't
make any changes to that so that is a uh
kpi that we are not going to be able to
achieve um uh in addition to that I
think we're on track really okay thank
you but happy to take any questions yeah
great okay thank you are there any
questions uh Ria then re thank you sham
I'm just wondering um when you say great
South's no longer managing the business
mentors NZ program in South Lan Could
you um what's the reason for that was it
simply a contractual delivery it was a
national decision to take it away from
any of the edas or any other agencies
that were delivering it on behalf so uh
business mentors themselves are
delivering that program now across New
Zealand okay thank you good thank you R
thanks chair look I think in in bagle is
experiencing and and as with the rest of
New Zealand influx of international
visitors plus more more people are
traveling in New Zealand
now um I've been uh contacted by both
hotel motel Cafe owners either when I'm
there or on the phone and the most
common question they're getting is where
is our Visitor Center now is that
something that is in great South South
domain or is that something you believe
Council should do uh because obviously
they are they just they have to say no
we don't know where it is there isn't
one no there isn't one um so I just want
to establish if I need to move this
forward is it great South that I come
knocking at your door or so just to um
query that Reg is so is that what
privacy was that situated at the Museum
you're talking about no no no not at all
so not was at the Museum and then in
wner place yeah it was so the is it
called The Visitor Center is it
coming iide is a branding so it is yeah
so but a visitor center let's call it a
visitor center at the moment without
getting into branding yeah uh that is a
deliverable that we said we'll look at a
feasability study for you um which is
being undertaken at the moment so
currently visitor information New
Zealand is the um company that holds the
eyesight branding and they restructured
how visitor centers should be oper
operational and um they've placed a lot
of emphasis on um how to present to an
international clientele obviously um
with that though there is a significant
investment so um they've categorized
eyes sites as into two different
categories category one and Category 2
for the sake of uh this conversation
we'll just leave it at that sorry um I
think they they just uh um identifi Us
in those two levels so category one is a
fully uh branded facility which costs so
they uh our Vin is uh willing to put up
$200,000 providing that uh the
RTO um or whatever business is going to
take on that Visitor Center puts on uh
an equal amount of money so essentially
for $400,000 they'll fit out a facility
um and so when we U mentioned this to uh
mayor Noby Clark initially uh and did
some initial um uh
calculations
the situation seems to be that you're
going to need about $300,000 to run it
and you're not going to have
commissionable products to be able to
manage that so um whether the council
wants to take it on as a community good
project or whether we look at a
different sort of model without actually
going through the eyesight branding and
just having a visitor center that is yet
to be determined but it will uh the
outcome of that will uh come once we
complete our feasibility report so that
we have a comprehensive uh report to
give to council so that a decision can
be made there after what sort of what
sort of can I ask what sort of time
frame for this because obviously staff
cost is is a critical one and U I guess
two options of sort of run rung around
New Zealand and um some visitor centers
are utilizing staff that are already
working either in a museum a library or
they're already working you know they
can share that um if someone's off sick
they can fill in and things like that
holiday stuff sort of more efficient and
then you've got the ones that are
totally Standalone and dedicated and
those whatever the staff are that's
their building and and yeah so is that
something you would you would look at
yes we will we'll give you the two
different options because under um
eyesight you have to have two dedicated
staff there you have to open seven days
a week there's certain criteria that you
You' got to meet which means your
overheads are going to be quite
significant initially when we did the uh
initial sort of um review on this we
were looking at uh HW tower on 25es
Street um but that uh the cost for that
lease was ex quite High um it's about
$888,000 at that time so like that on
top of Staffing cost and all of that
that's how we came up with this figure
about $300,000 is what you're going to
have to dish out can I can I ask my
final question um have you
approached any any of the people who are
involved in designing the new Museum
that that may be an alternative location
yeah I I can I can pick that up yeah
we've we've had a bit of work through
that you have through the council yeah
they work through it I think um right it
maybe my thought is sh me just around
like cuz clearly tourism's rebuilding
and I note the report I think real
Journeys well great South circulated
through it was a real Journeys report I
think recently um that talked about the
how they're expecting the big uplift and
visit us the steart or yeah com through
in the last
month so you know where visitors go and
that sort of thing is part of an overall
what's a strategy around tourism isn't
it so is it where is Great South ED
around um you know what does tourism
look like you know postco and you know
that sort of thing have you got any
thought on that or where are you at uh
yes I mean there there are certain um
projects that will come through from the
uh Miku destination strategy that was
recently launched um but also the fact
is like do we really need to have that
eyesight we've got an ambassador program
that we're rolling out where Frontline
staff will have information about you
know our uh region uh what's the story
behind it what's the history behind it
what's good where can you go you know so
various sort of of capability building
however um we feel given that the
numbers are growing given that you know
we've got 19 or so Crow Ships coming
through Bluff this season um so by next
year you know when we're catering to
increase this demand we need to have
some sort of visit a center so um the um
I I can't predetermine the report but it
seems quite likely that it will have to
be in a different form than being in
conformance with eyesight uh which is a
New Zealand wide brand but uh
irrespective the fact is we need to give
the information to the people who are
coming here and if we can get that out
to them in a cohesive um easy uh way
that is where we're going so we will
have some information on uh the digital
platform that we're planning to build so
tourism data and information will be
there but we've also got Southland and
said that lists all of our events that
lists all of the accommodations
restaurants the eateries things to do
events around here we host the um events
calendar for our region as well so that
that is available it's just about
getting that information out to our
visitors easily through a QR code or
something something and and it feels to
me anyway that you know it's more of a
digital sort of offering as opposed to a
physical offering given where the world
is and where it's possibly very much I
know whenever I'm going somewhere you
get on trip advisor and find out where
the best place to go for breakfast is
correct you know you don't yeah so it
seems like I mean you know we've got a
mall and we've got people going through
Bluff so it depends on how those
facilities are progress that we will
probably link into one of them we've
have spoken to toara uh distinction has
given an indication that they would you
know be willing to host um an
information center as well so there is a
there is definitely work that's being
undertaken but a comprehensive report
needs to come back to the council as it
is one of the um initiatives that we
said we will complete on behalf of ICC
yeah this when when would we receive
that Port um hopefully in quarter before
you know February or so this they are
being it is being worked on at the
moment so hopefully by February yeah and
then the council will be to see what the
sort of plan is correct thank you any
other
questions okay Ro thanks very much for
coming along I think we're going to put
you on a bit of a sort of a quarterly
program to come along and have a check
to us and just sort of yeah your wisdom
and insights and knowledge so you're
very welcome good thank
you um thank you um
so the we'll skip back to the financial
update so oh you've already the
resolutions that report we just done oh
right sorry yeah yeah it's all part of
one okay we have a recommendation in
three resolutions
so moved thank you Darren second Le any
questions all those in favor thank you
we'll go back when you make
you up so yeah we'll go back to our tab
6 point
update do the minutes first Mr no I
[Laughter]
don't decision well
you Financial update yeah Financial
update Financial update
um so this gives a financial update so
it's the standard Financial update paper
but as I mentioned in the quarterly
performance one we've actually given the
some high level financials through to
the treasury and net debt through to 30
November and I think the financials were
through to October so it just gives an
update of where we are at net debt is
continuing to track as we' expect we are
still seeing that in those interest
rates increase as but we're um the debt
that is rolling off is debt that's been
high as well so we've got a a shortterm
program there um and if there's I
prepared to take any
questions no um I've got one um and
thank you firstly for your report I
think it's really well laid out just was
respect on
page um 16 of all books one of the
reports
how much of the 60 odd million is um
income received in
advance
uh I can't say that off top of my head
but it won't be that much okay so it's a
true true reflection of net de yeah
right okay thank you any other
questions
yeah
no right oh can I sorry yes you can um
just for the Mao Central limited loan I
note that um was on page
18 and 17 that that will be drawn down
on December 23 has that happened already
yeah so there's a draw down that
happened today great um they will hit
maximum probably in January okay that's
good as the current um I don't think it
was
today sorry I think yeah I think they're
now expecting to hit their maximum in
January okay that's cool thank you
um I think was any
others no withy being none we'll seek a
mover in a second to receive that
report thanks Tom thanks Barry any final
questions okay all those in
favor against
carried we might as well keep moving and
go to strategic capital projects
there
welcome H then team how are you good
thank you end of the year Yes we made it
good um I hope you noticed the dress
code was um a little different from what
you wearing Le yeah U my jacket's
upstairs I think was a bit hot to be is
it bright red it's got to be bright red
though bright red I don't own a red
jacket maybe I'll try that for next year
you could borrow Michael I could borrow
Michaels are just maybe a different
[Laughter]
fit um I'm glad we got to the end of the
year and we're all still laughing so
that's cool yeah on the laugh Le that's
that's important yeah um like I think in
summary it's been a big year for the
team um we've delivered Lots we've got
lots in delivery
um our contractors are doing you know
good work for us our Consultants are
doing good work for us too um yeah I
think the report probably speaks for
itself but happy to take any questions
yeah thank
you any
questions here is a
m is a museum storage thing is it is it
going according to schedule the storage
facilties been hand putting stuff back
into the uh the relocation piece yes I
believe those guys have had a cracking
start um to be honest with you yeah noot
the uh the big red trucks are zooming in
and zooming out so I believe up bar it's
going real good yeah they have no issues
with the shelving or anything not as far
as I'm aware so far I believe they're
Trucking along real well that's fine
yeah just three Mr chair if I can answer
that with a bit more detail um that the
uh the movement using Crown um the crown
mov moving agency is um is is ahead of
schedule for the test period that
they've been using it over the last
couple of weeks um they were planning on
three to four movements um on average a
day of back and forth um they they've
achieved a couple of times of five uh
but but for ease of operation it's
probably a good average of four a day
that they'll be working towards in the
New Year obviously it's all based on the
on a pallet regime um so it's not on the
number of exhibits but on a pallet
regime I've asked the um the team
responsible for um delivering that to be
providing me with a fortn nightly report
so we can keep a running record against
plan for that as well so I'll have that
available for anyone who's interested on
an ongoing basis as
well yeah thanks RX that answers your
question y good R and then Tom um thank
you Lee I just want to go over the rugby
par um area that I've touched on before
that the roof is sort of challenge for
the team um the costing factor to that
because it's obviously it's specialized
areas that needs to deal to you've got
here that you've asked for some extra
time to work out what those costs are do
you have an idea how much more they
could be so um the way we've staged R
Park is we've done it in in lumps and
tranches so we've come to you we've
asked you for a lump of money to do a
certain scope of work so what we've
decided to do for the roof because it is
incredibly complicated uh and it's sort
of growing in arms and legs a wee bit
we've put that to one side and we've
what we're saying is we've got plenty of
money to do the current tranch which is
that corporate box improvements the
strengthening around the main stand
right um I actually we'll probably come
under budget for that piece for the roof
um the roof's going to be a good number
it's not been approved that that money
hasn't been approved by councel yet so
we'd have to bring that back back to you
guys to seek approval for that number um
I don't want to surmise what the number
will be but it's not going to be it's
going to I believe it be I think it'll
be within no no I think it'll be within
the overall ltp number that we have for
rby Park and I think it'll be well under
that okay but it'll still be you know a
Sub sub a substantial spend okay thank
you
Tom at the last council meeting we
talked about the naming protocol around
the storage facility and I think we
agreed that it would not be named until
the blessing ceremony and I know the the
blessing ceremony was postponed but the
name is out there because it was it was
in the paper so what was the pro I mean
have we officially named it
it
Mar through yourself chair so that
blessing ceremony is the um Tapo lifting
um ceremony where they hand it over that
was the one that's already um has
commenced the opening ceremony which
you're referring to will is occurring in
uh January I believe still February
sorry um with the final invites to come
out that's where the official opening
will be when we've got all of the
hopefully got all of the content inside
um but the name has been um gifted
across as part of that um ceremony and
announced yes so I think the process was
that it had to be blessed named and then
the move in started didn't it and so
that's what's happened correct and then
the opening ceremony was delayed because
of availability of
people yeah all
good let just back to the oh sorry
here sorry just a piece that I want to
draw attention to um and sorry Le I
think you briefed us on this but I'm I
just think it's worth bringing the
elected members attention to and that's
that you'll note that the museum has
moved into Amber for the first time um I
just think that it's just
usting that although we still have some
float in the program um that project is
just one that we need to keep a close
eye on to make sure that we keep it
tracking um and are able to achieve that
1225 program there is sufficient float
at the moment but we're having to work
hard to keep it
moving yeah and that's largely due to
design isn't it y but it's it's sort of
a detailed design is it yes the current
the current design stage is is a bit
behind yeah and they are being pushed
pretty hard yeah um and it is probably
given us our first uh first real want or
need to put that to Amber and just keep
a very very close brief on that I mean
it's literally daily daily check-ins now
with that with that team yeah yeah and
yeah thanks for your efforts on keeping
that project running L I know you've
been putting a few bit of oil on Wheels
yep definitely um any further
questions no so yeah just I just comment
around you know I think it has been a
really big year project team I think's
done a really great job of keeping
things on track and there's been a lot
of in the year sometimes feels like
there's too many but you've done a great
job beond the team so thank you very
much appreciate that thank you I
pass okay so we will um we got
recommendations there receive the
project report Capital project report
and the pmo report and note the current
status so I have a move thanks very and
Tom any final questions okay all those
in favor hi
I
right so I think we can do your minutes
now
Michael okay so we'll go back to T four
just the minutes of the finance and
projects meeting held on the 17th of
October thank you Darren second thanks
liy um so is there any questions or
queries relating to those
minutes
no okay that been
moved all those in favor
I carried right minutes of the
extraordinary finance and project
meeting committee meeting held on the
14th of November move those you thanks
Darren any questions or
queries okay there being none
all those in favor I against carried
right excluded Mr yes so we want to move
now to public
excluded so thank you bar and
second thanks Tom okay the reasons for a
public exclusion
are listed
um